allein für diese nachricht hat sich die
große bild kanzler nachdem gestern
gelohnt gestern abend der sagte armin
laschet bei uns die 50er inzidenz solle
fallen und jetzt twittert
gesundheitsminister jens spahn die 50er
incidents hat ausgedient armin laschet
hatte recht sie war der maßstab bei
einer ungeimpften bevölkerung mein
vorschlag ist sie aus dem gesetz zu
streichen als neuer parameter gehört die
zahl der ins krankenhaus aufgenommen
sowie patienten ins gesetzt werden
entscheidend ist wie stark unser
gesundheitssystem durch bewohner noch
belastet wird danach sollten wir unsere
maßnahmen ausrichten und auf genau das
haben wir auch christine lambrecht
vorhin vor einer stunde bei uns in der
sendung festlegen können aus sie hat
gesagt die fünfziger inzidenz dollar
fallen und jetzt fragen wer den fdp chef
christian lindner der das gestrige duell
auch verfolgt hat und hier bei uns im
studio ist zusammen mit julian reichelt
zufrieden mit der
nachricht
endlich muss man sagen
dass pandemie geschehen hat sich
verändert und deshalb muss sich die
pandemie politik auch verändern wir
können nicht weiter die sonderbefugnisse
bei der bundesregierung habe das
parlament muss wieder alle seine rechte
wahrnehmen können die orientierung an
der inzidenz hat uns zu keinem zeitpunkt
überzeugt haben ja lange vorgeschlagen
etwa die positiv quote an der gesamtzahl
der tests und eben die situation in den
krankenhäusern mit aufzunehmen ich
erwarte von der regierung jetzt aber
eigentlich noch mehr nämlich eine
politische garantie dass es im herbst
nicht zu neuen pauschalen
freiheitseinschränkung und kommt geimpft
und genesen sind nicht gefährlich und
von ungeimpften und negativ getesteten
geht in dieser phase der pandemie auch
nicht mehr eine gefahr aus wie noch vor
einem jahr
christian sie haben das duell gestern
bei uns verfolgt die beiden interviews
mit den beiden kanzlerkandidaten armin
laschet und olaf scholz
spektakuläre umfragen gerade 22 22 die
beiden gleichauf man kann sagen es ist
derzeit sehr wahrscheinlich dass einer
von den beiden kanzler wird und damit
kommt ihnen eine ganz besondere rolle zu
den beiden können eigentlich nur kanzler
werden wenn die fdp mit macht würde die
fdp eine ampel mitmachen
die guten umfragewerte von olaf scholz
erklären sich auch mit der tatsache dass
es herrn scholz jetzt seit mehreren
wochen gut gelungen ist saskia esken und
kevin kühnert vor der öffentlichkeit zu
verbergen
vielleicht hätte sie nach dem ende oder
nach den wahlen am wahlabend am 26
september wieder rausholen aber nochmal
ein spannendes szenario was unsere
demoskopen von insm aufgemacht haben wir
haben derzeit eine hohe zahl der so
genannten sonstigen kleine parteien die
nicht die fünf-prozent-hürde schaffen 78
prozent ungefähr damit reicht es mit 45
46 prozent im parlament für eine
mehrheit der zeit könnte es reichen für
eine linke mehrheit im parlament für rot
rot grün wird olaf scholz vermutlich
nicht machen aber könnte zu christian
lindner kommen und sagen wenn du
deutschland von den kommunisten retten
willst dann kommen unsere ampel was
machen sie in dem szenario ich glaube
nicht dass olaf scholz mit solchen
erpressungsversuchen erarbeiten würde
dazu ist er ein zu
respektabler kandidat und das würde auch
nicht zur partei von willy brandt passen
sich so
auf suche nach koalitionspartnern zu
begeben tatsächlich ist es nicht
ausgeschlossen dass ist eine
rot-grün-rote konstellation ergeben
könnte es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass
auch schwarz-grün noch eine mehrheit
erzielt gerade vor dem hintergrund der
quote für die sonstigen die sie
geschildert haben und deshalb kann man
nur den menschen sagen wählen sie fdp
für eine eine politik der mitte bitte
keine sonstigen bitte nicht die ränder
stark machen wer armin laschet mit den
grünen nicht allein lassen will der
sollte ebenfalls die fdp wählen zur
ampel schauen sie erreicht wenn man sich
die inhalte ansieht spd und grüne stehen
in den programmen in der wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik in wahrheit doch der
linkspartei und nicht der fdp sehr nahe
olaf scholz selbst hat vor einer wahl in
hamburg einmal ausgeschlossen mit der
fdp zu koalieren hat sich vor der wahl
festgelegt auf die grünen obwohl
sozialliberal möglich gewesen wäre dass
er jetzt also über sozial liberal
spricht ist für mich jedenfalls nicht
überzeugend ich gehe unverändert davon
aus dass herr laschet bundeskanzler wird
entscheidend ist nur wird er das tun nur
mit den grünen oder kann die fdp dazu
kommen als garant für eine politik der
mitte wir haben mal kurz rein was soll
das soll es gestern abgesagt hat
da ein starkes ergebnis der union dass
gegen die union jedenfalls nicht ein
bündnis gebildet werden kann kein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis das wäre glaube
ich wirklich gift für unsere wirtschaft
gift auch für den wohlstand in
deutschland aber auch viele ideen die
spd und grüne haben halte ich für
gefährlich für unsere wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und für unsere stabilität
jamina schritt war das natürlich armin
laschet war es nicht olaf scholz man
erkennt ihn ganz eindeutig armin laschet
hat gestern gesagt für ihn ist immer
noch die 30 prozent drin derzeit steht
dabei 22 kämpfte also um acht
prozentpunkte einige davon will er
vermutlich von der fdp und man hat im
moment ein bisschen das gefühl dabei
könnte die große politiker und
männerfreundschaft lindner laschet
vielleicht schaden leiden sie regieren
zusammen in nrw aber der ton den die
union derzeit gegenüber der fdp
anschlägt ist schon bemerkenswert für
weggefährten und koalitionspartner
das muss man entschuldigen mit der
schwierigen lage der cdu wir nehmen das
sehr sportlich armin laschet hat auch er
vor der nrw-landtagswahl
2017 mit der cdu intensiv davor gewarnt
die fdp zu wählen
es drohe eine ampel christian lindner
könnte hannelore kraft zur
ministerpräsidentin machen das kennen
sie also schon das kenne ich schon lange
versucht mit ja das kenne ich und auf
ihre kosten ja das stimmt und die
wählerinnen und wähler in
nordrhein-westfalen 2017 haben es aber
als das entfernt was es ist nämlich
wahlkampf folklore die fdp hat
seinerzeit das beste ergebnis ihrer
geschichte in nrw erzielt deshalb wurde
armin laschet auch nur ministerpräsident
in einer schwarz gelben koalition
ich sollte auf jamaika hinauslaufen
würden sie noch mal weg laufen jetzt ist
jamaika ein ganz anderes was sie
übrigens weglaufen das nenne ich
verhindern eines links trifft in
deutschland denn frau merkel hatte mit
den grünen genau das beabsichtigt und
für neue und mehr linke politik steht
die fdp nicht zur verfügung weil wir
haben schon sehr viele linke politik in
deutschland umverteilung wir haben sehr
viel bürokratismus sehr viel staat wir
brauchen nicht noch mehr linke politik
sondern wir brauchen eine politik die
wieder mehr freiräume eröffnet mit ihren
13 prozent mit denen sie derzeit ja ganz
gut dastehen könnt ihr natürlich mit
etwas breiterer brust auftreten und sie
sind der königsmacher darauf geld ist ja
es gibt aber es geht hier um uns um
inhalte und das wäre auch wenn ich das
so sagen darf meine
an meine erwartung dass die cdu ihre
strategie verändert nicht empfehlung
muss den nichts empfehlen aber ich
glaube wenn die union erfolgreich sein
will dann sollte sie sich stärker an
inhalten orientieren sich also nicht mit
der fdp auseinandersetzen sondern zum
beispiel mit den grünen und deren ideen
für den umbau der gesellschaft armin
laschet könnte klarstellen ob es mit ihm
ein aufweichen der schuldenbremse gibt
ja oder nein und ob er klar
steuererhöhungen ausschließt da fährt
der lader schlangenlinien da warten wir
darauf ganz herzlichen dank herr lindner
für ihren besuch im studio
[Musik]